ist der weg noch bis zu ein gesetz mit
einer verschärfung dann durch ist genau
das haben wir gerade auch noch mal in
hannover die spd chefin saskia esken
gefragt kommt dieses gesetz noch vor der
sommerpause wollten wir wissen
das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen ja
nicht gesagt aber möglich also wissen
wir haben in den letzten in den letzten
wochen und monaten erlebt wie schnell
politik gehen können ganz neu auch
erfahren dass man ja ehrlich sagen also
in so einem mist mittel ich bin mir
sicher das ist ganz wichtig ist dass wir
an der stelle auch klarheit schaffen
dass wir auch deutlich signalisieren
dass er kindesmissbrauch und auch
kinderpornografie als verbrechen
empfinden dass auf jeden fall machen und
zwar als verbrechen das auch konsequent
verfolgt und bestraft werden muss aber
vor allem auch verhindert werden muss
und darum geht es dass wir prävention
stärken und dass wir auch die polizei
behörden stärken dann ende ermittelt